die aus
der Corona-Krise hervorgehen,
z. B., dass Deutschland
an den Lippen von Virologen hängt.
Eine wohltuende Abwechslung,
wenn auch mal Wissenschaftler
in den Medien den Ton angeben.
Aber Wissenschaft und Medien
sind so 'ne Sache.
Wie ihr
von unserem Format "Schlagzeilen
wissenschaftlich geprüft" wisst,
kann man sich darauf verlassen,
dass es immer Artikel oder Beiträge
geben wird, die Wissenschaft
verkürzt, missverständlich
oder falsch darstellen.
Aber sind nur
die Journalisten schuld
oder tragen die Wissenschaftler auch
zur Verwirrung bei? Spoiler: ja.
Das schauen wir uns heute an
anhand der derzeit beliebtesten
Wissenschaftler: Virologen.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2020)
Nur damit
das niemand falsch versteht:
Ich möchte natürlich nicht den
Virologen ihre Forschung erklären,
das wäre ja Mai-Splaining.
Mir geht es in diesem Video
um gute Wissenschaftskommunikation
auf Seiten der Wissenschaftler
und guten Wissenschaftsjournalismus
auf Seiten der Medien.
Denn beides ist
in dieser Corona-Krise
genauso wichtig
wie die Forschung selbst.
Schauen wir dazu auf die 3
bekanntesten Virologen Deutschlands.
Erstens:
Prof. Dr. Christian Drosten.
Er ist absoluter Spezialist
für Coronaviren.
Sein Team hat u. a. den weltweit
1. Test fürs neue Virus entwickelt.
Die meisten kennen ihn von seinem
täglichen Corona-Update-Podcast.
Zweitens:
Prof. Dr. Hendrick Streeck.
V. a. seit letzter Woche
sind er und sein Team wegen
der Heinsberg-Studie in aller Munde.
Die bekommt viel
Aufmerksamkeit und Kritik.
Drittens:
Prof. Dr. Alexander Kekulé.
Der Virologe und Epidemiologe ist,
untypisch für einen Wissenschaftler,
nicht um klare Ansagen
und deutliche politische
Handlungsempfehlungen verlegen.
Das macht wahrscheinlich
auch Kekulé Appeal aus,
denn die meisten
wollen nicht in 1. Linie
wissenschaftliche Grundlagen
verstehen,
sondern wir wollen
natürlich in 1. Linie wissen,
was wir aus der Forschung für uns,
für unseren Alltag,
für den Krisenumgang
ableiten können.
Um es in den Worten des wunderbaren
Wissenschafts-Kommunikators
Jean-Luc Doumont zu sagen:
Wissenschaftler
beschäftigen sich mit "What?",
die Leute aber interessieren
sich für "So what?".
Mhm, sehr interessant diese Studie,
aber was heißt das für mich?
Diese Differenzierung
von "What?" und "So what?"
macht gute
Wissenschaftskommunikation
und guten
Wissenschaftsjournalismus aus.
Also lasst doch schauen,
was die "Whats?" und "So whats?"
unserer 3 Virologen sind:
Fangen wir an mit Prof. Drosten.
Vielen ist gar nicht bewusst,
was für ein Glück wir haben,
dass einer der wenigen weltweit
führenden Corona-Experten
zufälligerweise ein Deutscher ist,
uns also in unserer Muttersprache
aufklären kann
und das auch noch macht.
Ich hab auf Twitter immer
wieder so salty Kommentare gelesen,
dass man ihn nicht so abfeiern soll,
dafür, dass er
"nur seinen Job macht".
Erstens: Bitch, das ist nicht sein
Job. Sein Job ist es, zu forschen,
nicht die
breite Öffentlichkeit aufzuklären.
Leider ist das nicht Teil
seines Jobs, liebe Frau Karliczek,
vielleicht können Sie das ändern.
Wissenschaftskommunikation
kostet Zeit.
Zeit, die dir in der Wissenschaft
niemand entlohnt, im Gegenteil.
Zweitens: Wissenschaftskommunikation
ist verdammt schwierig.
Wissenschaft ist hochkomplex,
aber Medien, die an eine breite
Öffentlichkeit gerichtet sind,
lassen meistens
nicht den nötigen Raum,
um die Komplexität zu vermitteln.
Am Ende wirst du
noch beschimpft für Sachen,
die du so nicht gesagt hast.
Drittens: Warum sollten wir
WissenschaftlerInnen nicht abfeiern,
"nur" für ihre Arbeit?
# ... is a virus
you don't need a venture
# what you need are
kind of fucking educated nerds
# thank god for
the motherfucking nerds right now
# thank god
for the motherfucking nerds
Jedenfalls, als Corona-Experte,
der auch noch eloquent ist,
liefert Drosten dem Laien
unglaublich viel "What?".
Bisher hat er über
1000 Minuten Podcast aufgezeichnet
und beglückt uns Hörer
mit einem wissenschaftlichen Niveau,
das man sonst
in den Medien selten bekommt.
"... Also modified vaccinia ankara,
neutralisierende Antikörper
provozieren.
Dazu kann man bestimmte
Impf-Antigene verwenden.
Kurze Zeitpunkte
im Replikationszyklus,
wo diese Domänen
wirklich offenlegen ..."
Dieses Nerdfest kommentiert er
übrigens in derselben Folge so:
"Wir können das in diesem Podcast
nur so in diesem oberflächlichen
Anfangsniveau besprechen."
Das noch mal als Erinnerung daran,
dass man kein Virologe wird,
indem man einen Podcast hört.
Er betont immer sehr deutlich,
wenn er über Dinge außerhalb
seiner Spezialisierung spricht.
"Ich muss wieder dazusagen,
ich bin kein Impfstoff-Forscher,
ich bin ein allgemeiner
Wald-und-Wiesen-Virologe,
vielleicht mit Spezialkenntnissen
zu epidemischen Coronaviren."
Und das, obwohl es absolut innerhalb
seiner Qualifikation liegt,
einer breiten Bevölkerung
Impfstoff-Basics zu erklären.
Aber noch vorsichtiger und
differenzierter drückt er sich aus,
wenn es um "So what?"-Fragen geht.
Er betont z. B. immer
wieder den Unterschied
zwischen wissenschaftlichen
Entscheidungsgrundlagen
und politischen Entscheidungen.
"Die Entscheidungen
muss die Politik ja treffen.
Ich versuche das
auch immer klarzustellen."
Zusammengefasst finde ich
Drostens Wissenschaftskommunikation
sehr gelungen.
Er geht verantwortungsvoll
mit seinem Expertenstatus um.
Ich hätte nur ein kleines Hühnchen
mit ihm zu rupfen,
aber dazu kommen wir
am Ende des Videos.
Machen wir erst mal weiter mit den
Medienauftritten von Prof. Streeck.
Auch mit ihm haben wir das Glück,
einen angesehenen Fachexperten
im Land zu haben,
der gerade mit Hochdruck
Hands-on-Forschung vor Ort,
genauer gesagt
in Heinsberg betreibt.
Doch in seiner Kommunikation
ist er nicht immer so vorsichtig
wie etwa Kollege Drosten. Z. B.
fiel mir diese Pauschalierung auf.
"Ich finde das Problem
in unserer Diskussion bisher,
dass wir sehr über Spekulationen
und Modellrechnungen reden.
Da muss ja nur ein Faktor
in so 'ner mathematischen Rechnung
falsch sein,
dann fällt das alles zusammen
wie ein Kartenhaus."
Das wurde natürlich
direkt von der Presse gefressen.
Das ist eine Verkürzung,
die bei Laien
das Vertrauen in die wichtige Arbeit
von Epidemiologen und deren
Modellrechnungen erschüttern kann.
Im letzten Video bezog
ich mich auch auf Modellrechnungen.
Gewisse Parameter der Epidemie
sind noch nicht bekannt.
Hier mussten Annahmen
getroffen werden.
Aber dafür macht man auch
verschiedene Szenarien auf.
Man berechnet
ein Best-Case-Szenario,
ein Worst-Case-Szenario
und einiges dazwischen.
Man verlässt sich also nicht
auf einzelne, geratene Parameter,
sondern
auf ganze Parameter-Bereiche,
also auf Größenordnungen.
Prof. Streecks Untersuchungen
in Heinsberg können dabei helfen,
diese Parameter
genauer zu bestimmen.
Damit aber so eine Modellrechnung
"zusammenfällt wie ein Kartenhaus",
müssten die Parameter in einer
völlig anderen Größenordnung liegen.
Ein Parameter ist die Sterblichkeit,
also die Anzahl der Todesfälle
geteilt durch
die Anzahl der Infizierten.
Aber nicht alle Infizierten
werden entdeckt oder gemeldet,
z. B. die sehr milden Fälle.
Es gibt also eine Dunkelziffer.
Wenn diese Dunkelziffer
viel höher ist,
also ich meine
viel höher als bisher erwartet,
dann wäre auch die Infizierten-Zahl
deutlich höher als angenommen,
und damit auch die Zahl der Leute,
die schon immun sind.
Und die Sterblichkeit wäre viel
niedriger als bisher angenommen.
In Heinsberg bzw. Gangelt
konnte Streeck eine Sterblichkeit
von 0,37 % ermitteln.
Das ist erst mal
nur repräsentativ für die Region.
Ob diese Zahl für ganz Deutschland
übertragbar ist,
wird sich noch zeigen. Die
Größenordnung könnte aber stimmen.
Denn Sterblichkeit
liegt mit diesem 0,37%
innerhalb
des bisher geschätzten Bereichs.
Die Schätzungen gingen bisher
von 1,3% in einem schlimmen Fall
bis 0,1% in einem guten Fall.
Also "What?":
Diese Zwischenergebnisse
konkretisieren das,
was bisher grob geschätzt wurde.
"So what?": Unsere Lage ist genauso
ernst wie bisher angenommen.
"Hä?", denken sich jetzt manche.
Hieß es nicht, dass
die Heinsberg-Studio Hoffnung macht
auf Lockerung der Maßnahmen?
Wie passt das zusammen?
Gar nicht.
Es passt gar nicht zusammen.
Das "What?" und das "So what?"
haben nichts miteinander zu tun. Hm.
Ein "Spiegel"-Artikel, den Streeck
selbst als gute Darstellung teilte,
trägt die irreführende Überschrift
"Jeder Siebte
könnte bereits immun sein".
Das bezieht sich natürlich
nur auf Gangelt, also auf den Ort,
an dem es einen
der größten Ausbrüche gab.
Für Deutschland gilt nach wie vor,
dass wahrscheinlich nicht viel
mehr als 1% der Menschen immun sind.
Nun ist Streeck unter viel Beschuss
geraten in den letzten Tagen,
aus verschiedenen Gründen,
aber v. a. wegen der Kommunikation,
v. a. durch die professionelle
PR-Agentur "Storymachine".
Ich will nur ergänzen, ich finde
es prinzipiell völlig in Ordnung,
wenn man sich professionelle Hilfe
für seine
Wissenschaftskommunikation sucht.
Also selbst wenn man
eine professionelle PR hat,
muss das nicht automatisch
auf Kosten der
wissenschaftlichen Qualität gehen.
Man muss aber als Wissenschaftler
die Verantwortung übernehmen
für die wissenschaftliche
Korrektheit der eigenen PR.
Und ich finde es in dieser
aktuellen Ausnahme-Situation
auch prinzipiell legitim,
wenn man
wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse
nicht auf dem normalen Weg, sondern
via Pressekonferenz mitteilt,
wenn man denn meint:
Das, was ich rausgefunden habe,
ist so relevant
für Politik und Gesellschaft,
es ist meine Verantwortung
als Wissenschaftler,
diese Entscheidungsgrundlage
nicht vorzuenthalten.
Aber selbst wenn man davon ausgeht,
dass die Zwischenergebnisse
einwandfrei sind,
sind sie eine Bestätigung
unserer aktuellen Lage,
eben nicht
eine Entscheidungsgrundlage
für eine Lockerung der Maßnahmen.
Zusammenfassung:
Prof. Streeck mag sauber und
ordentlich in seiner Forschung sein,
in seiner Kommunikation
ist er es leider nicht.
Mir ist aufgefallen, dass er öfter
seine Meinung als "Bürger" kundtut.
"Also man sollte
über eine Exitstrategie
doch langsam nachdenken?
- Ich persönlich,
wieder als Bürger gesprochen, halte
es für extrem wichtig. - Ich auch."
Was ich prinzipiell
natürlich legitim finde.
Auch Wissenschaftler
dürfen und sollen Menschen
mit persönlichen Meinungen sein.
Nur: Er drückt sich dabei so aus,
dass ein Laie
nur schwer nachvollziehen kann,
ob seine "Bürgermeinung"
auch auf seiner wissenschaftlichen
Expertise fußt oder nicht.
Ich hoffe, dass Prof. Streeck
seine Glaubwürdigkeit
nicht durch missverständliche
Kommunikation weiter verspielt.
Ich bin nach wie vor sehr gespannt
auf die Studienergebnisse,
die uns hoffentlich
mit fundierten Hinweisen versorgen,
wie wir unsere Maßnahmen
intelligent anpassen können.
Kommen wir zu Prof. Kekulé:
Kekulé wird manchmal
fast despektierlich
als "Medienexperte" bezeichnet.
Volker Stollorz,
Wissenschaftsjournalist
und Leiter des
Science Media Centers sieht das so:
"Denn das ist eher so, was ich
einen öffentlichen Experten nenne,
der immer wieder gerne
von Journalisten befragt wird.
Aber er selbst
hat seit vielen Jahren nichts mehr
zum Fortschritt der Forschung im
Bereich der Virologie beigetragen.
Über Coronaviren
hat er faktisch nie publiziert.
Da steht nichts in
den wissenschaftl. Datenbanken.
Er ist jemand, der seine Autorität
als Professor geschickt nutzt,
um seine eigene Meinung zu äußern.
Er sucht selbst auch das
Rampenlicht der Öffentlichkeit.
Das ist wiederum lukrativ
für Journalisten.
Weil wenn Experten sozusagen leicht
erreichbar und auch bekannt sind,
wächst sozusagen
ihre Prominenz in den Medien.
Aber das ist kein Qualitätssiegel
innerhalb der Forschung."
Gut, man kann trotzdem nicht von
der Hand weisen, dass Prof. Kekulé
virologische und epidemiologische
Fachexpertise hat.
Auch grundsätzlich
finde ich nicht,
dass man selbst
an Corona forschen muss,
um einer breiten Öffentlichkeit
wissenschaftl. Grundlagen
zu erklären.
Nur darf man,
wie Volker Stollorz richtig sagt,
nicht Medienpräsenz
automatisch gleichsetzen
mit Kompetenz oder Korrektheit.
Aber genau das machen viele Laien.
Deswegen, finde ich,
je größer die Reichweite,
desto verantwortlicher
muss man mit seiner
Wissenschaftskommunikation
und seinem Expertenstatus umgehen.
Wir haben
uns vieles von dem angeguckt,
was Kekulé in den letzten Wochen
geschrieben oder gesagt hat.
Ich sag mal so:
Wenn man seine Meinung
oder Einordnung ändert, anpasst
auf Basis neuer Erkenntnisse,
ist das sehr wichtig und richtig,
aber es gibt
einige Widersprüchlichkeiten
in seinen Aussagen, die sich
dadurch nicht erklären lassen
und die wir nicht
nachvollziehen konnten.
Wir hatten teilweise Probleme,
die wissenschaftliche Grundlage
für seine sehr klaren Ansagen
nachzuvollziehen.
Wie etwa die sehr deutlichen
"So whats?" in diesem tweet:
Lars hat Kekulé eine Presseanfrage
mit 2 unserer größten
Verständnis-Fragen geschickt.
Ihr könnt das Video kurz pausieren,
um sie euch durchzulesen.
Dann versteht ihr,
dass wir ernsthafte Probleme haben,
manches nachzuvollziehen.
Leider hat uns
Prof. Kekulé abgesagt.
Ich muss dazu fairerweise sagen,
dass wir ihm nur ein paar Tage Zeit
geben konnten für die Antwort.
Virologen haben
ja viel zu tun dieser Tage.
Aber solange diese Verständnis-
Fragen nicht plausibel erklärt sind,
macht für mich schon
allein das "What?" keinen Sinn.
Zusammenfassend: Wenn schon
das "What?" nicht schlüssig ist,
wäre ich sehr vorsichtig damit, so
klare "So what?"-Ansagen zu machen.
So, und jetzt zu meiner letzten
Kritik. Die geht an Prof. Drosten.
Drosten kritisiert an mehreren
Stellen Medien, mit gutem Grund.
Denn obwohl er sich so sorgfältig
und differenziert ausdrückt,
werden auch seine Aussagen immer
wieder aus dem Kontext gerissen
oder verkürzt dargestellt, wie
z. B. bei diesem "Stern"-Interview.
Er verurteilt außerdem den Personen-
Kult um sich und seine Kollegen.
"Es gibt Zeitungen, die malen
inzwischen nicht nur in den Wörtern,
sondern in Bildern
Karikaturen von Virologen.
Ich sehe mich
selber als Comic-Figur gezeichnet.
Und mir wird schlecht dabei.
Ich bin wirklich wütend darüber,
wie hier Personen
für ein Bild missbraucht werden,
das Medien zeichnen wollen,
um zu kontrastieren.
Das muss wirklich aufhören."
Auch Streeck fällt dem gerade
zum Opfer, ob er will oder nicht:
So beginnt die "Bild" ihren Artikel,
als ob das was zur Sache täte.
Jetzt packen die Journalisten
anscheinend das Popcorn aus
und schreiben einen großen Streit
zwischen Drosten und Streeck herbei.
Dagegen wehrt sich Drosten
aber öffentlich und entschieden.
Seiner Medien-Kritik kann ich
mich grundsätzlich anschließen,
also dem "What?".
Aber mit dem "So what?",
also mit den Schlussfolgerungen,
die er daraus zieht,
damit habe ich ein Problem.
"Eine Sache kann
und darf die Wissenschaft nicht,
hat die Wissenschaft nicht,
nämlich die Wissenschaft
hat kein demokratisches Mandat.
Ein Wissenschaftler
ist kein Politiker.
Er wurde nicht gewählt
und muss nicht zurücktreten.
Und kein Wissenschaftler will
überhaupt so Dinge sagen wie:
Diese politische Entscheidung
war richtig oder falsch
oder muss jetzt
als nächstes getroffen werden.
Sie hören das
von keinem seriösen Wissenschaftler.
Dennoch wird
immer weiter dieses Bild
des entscheidungstreffenden
Wissenschaftlers
in den Medien produziert.
Und wir sind hier,
glaube ich, langsam an dem Punkt,
wo die Wissenschaft in geordneter
Weise den Rückzug antreten muss,
wenn das nicht aufhört."
Wissenschaftler
sind keine Politiker, klar.
Politische Entscheidungen
beinhalten viele Aspekte,
natürlich nicht nur
naturwissenschaftliche
und Evidenz-basierte,
sondern gesellschaftliche,
soziale, ethische, auch klar.
Trotzdem sind Wissenschaftler
als Experten ganz wesentlich
für den Weg raus
aus dieser Epidemie.
# Thank god for
the motherfucking nerds right now
Auch wenn am Ende die Politik
die Entscheidungen treffen muss,
sollten wir die konstruktiven
Bewertungen der Entscheidungen
nicht nur anderen Politikern
und Journalisten überlassen,
sondern auch den Experten.
Und wenn das öffentlich passiert,
profitieren wir alle
von der Expertise.
Also wir gewinnen an
Nachvollziehbarkeit und Verständnis
für die nächsten Entscheidungen.
Deswegen,
liebe WissenschaftlerInnen,
bitte natürlich keinen geordneten
Rückzug aus den Medien antreten.
In der aktuellen Medienlandschaft,
wo Journalismus
durch Werbeklicks überleben muss,
ist Zuspitzung
und Dramatisierung auch gleich Geld.
Die meisten
Wissenschaftsjournalisten
machen trotzdem
gute und gewissenhafte Arbeit,
aber wir könnten Verstärkung
gebrauchen an der sachlichen Front.
Herr Drosten, Sie regen sich
zu Recht über Zuspitzungen
oder Verkürzungen in den Medien auf.
Aber genau deswegen
brauchen wir nicht weniger,
sondern mehr Fachleute
in den Medien.
Ansonsten entsteht nur mehr Platz
für Personen oder Akteure,
die es mit der wissenschaftlichen
Korrektheit nicht so ernst nehmen
wie Sie.
Also, liebe WissenschaftlerInnen,
wir brauchen gute
Wissenschaftskommunikation,
teilt eure Expertise,
tragt zur Aufklärung bei.
Nur achtet dabei sorgfältig auf
eure "Whats?" und "So whats?",
sonst mache ich
ein Video über euch.
Freunde der Sonne,
danke für eure überwältigende
Resonanz zum letzten Video.
Falls es jemand noch nicht gesehen
hat, hier ist das noch mal.
Und wer keine 22 Minuten Zeit hat,
es gibt einen deutlich kürzeren
Tagesthemen-Kommentar von mir.
Den verlinke ich euch auch.
Ich bin auch
auf Twitter und Instagram.
Wir sehen uns in 2 Wochen.
Bis dahin, bleibt sicher.